One of the unique properties of
a map over just a regular old
object, is that you can actually
use an object as the key in a
map. What I mean by that is,
let's say we had an object right
here and we wanted to use a
object as the key. We can't do
that. We can only use a string,
where we say key, or wes, or hi,
that's the only thing. But
what if we were able to use an
object here, where the value can
be a number, a string, or
another object itself? That's
where maps come in really handy,
because they can be used as sort
of a metadata dictionary, where
it holds information about an
object but it doesn't
necessarily put that information
on the object. Let's say I
had a bunch of buttons right
here, and every time I click one
of those buttons I want to
record how many times that
specific button was clicked.
I could put the click count
right on the element itself, but
I don't really want to do that
because it's kind of dirty, and
if I remove the element then
that count is gone with it. I
could also create an object
where I take something unique
about this button and use that.
Maybe I give them each an ID.
But in this case, we can
actually use the button itself
because when I select it it's
going to be an object. We'll use
that as the actual key. Let's
make a new map called
clickCounts, and then let's
select every single button on
the page. Now I'm going to loop
over every single button and add
it to this map, and we're going
to set it by default zero.
That's the actual click count.
So, button. for each button.
Then for each button, we're
going to add it to the map.
Notice how the key is going to
just be the button itself. Let's
save that and we'll take a look
at...Oh, it's document.query.
Select all. Take a look at
our click counts. Look, this is
our map, whereas every single
key...look at that. The key is a
button. I can open that up and
you see that that's just a
regular DOM node element right
there. The key is an actual
object. That's really handy.
Now when someone clicks one of
these, we'll just increment the
number by one. Say, button.
avidListener, then I could say
val get...what is the key to get?
This, right? Because I used a
regular function there, this is
going to be equal to the button.
So get this. Then we'll just
console.log the val here and see
what each one is. Zero, zero,
obviously they're all zero right
now. Then we can set it. Say
click counts.set. This with the
key is going to be the button,
and then the value is just going
to be val plus one, incremented
by one. Then I'm going to
console.log the click
counts entire map, just to see
what we're dealing with now.
Good. So now we click snakes,
open that sucker up, you see the
first button which is this one,
has a value of one. You could
use an object or a string, or
anything. I'm just using a
regular old number. If I
click it a few more times, here
we go. You can see that every
time I click one of these, the
click count is going on up.
That's a useful case for using a
map where you want to store
metadata, not necessarily on the
object, but you want to store
metadata about an object. A map
is a good use case for that.